d'abonnés l'aréna la merci venel a donné
à mathieu venez là bas jamais venez là
venez là bas venait revient l'arbre
pascal bel avant pascal et voilà c'est
bon gardien maxime mecheri il y a il y a
quatre cartes ici il ya quatre cartes
ici il y a une carte sumo et trois
cartes touche pas à mon poste
celui qui a la carte humeau sera en sumo
dans un instant pour affronter macao
d'accord c'est obligatoire est
obligatoire attention c'est pas tant
donné alors tenez moi alors deux mois la
mienne je te donne tu me donnes à vienne
vas-y manie très bien joué à l'italienne
à lévis à 2,3
bon j'ai pas le choix
très foncé
alors
hélas très cher il raconté jean le cam
et je le jure vraiment dur on sent quand
à la tonne c'est en suivant autonome à
l'instant mais on va tout jouer
vasic ce qui t'arrive tu vois rien je te
comptes tu me cote comme ça ça va partir
je te dis ça mais l'appétit
vas-y rescator je me mets ton macao bien
mon chéri c'est très c'est très
important pour toi je t'explique tu vas
avoir quatre combattants qui vont avec
face à toi il monte et ils ont très mal
mais le truc très mal gérard quatre
combattants qui va se passer à tout vent
de face à toi tu rares moi d'abord mais
moi est pourtant craignait alors tout de
suite
pascal le grand frère que tu vas devoir
également affronter et il y aura un
troisième combattant très très bas
l'aise si tu bats les trois combattants
au sumo c'est à dire si tu arrive à nous
faire sortir du cercle tu partiras et je
te jure que c'est vrai à macao avec la
personne de son choix
avec qui tu vas partir à macao avec qui
tu vas partir à macao avec une sauce
tassos à tu pars avec une sauce tartare
au skate shop sauce moutarde sign of
time of time of arrête de me pousser
comme ça ça va partir qui restent
relégables
il est sympa le président pas super
sympa parce qu'elle garde du corps de
deux des manuels bacon franchement dans
ses récits sympa pour l'institut en
parlant je peux pas en parler mais on ne
sait rien à dire ils ont sol à coeur non
donc tu l'écris qovu brigitte emmanuel à
willer faire un petit coucou l'a pas dit
gros bisous aux chefs maumus gros mise à
la première dame résidant à quoi tu me
vois comme ça tu dis moi que tu aurais
dû prendre à vrai dire l'oeuf moi si on
arrêtait direct comme s'abîme pascal tu
vas affronter macao dans un instant
d'abord on va certainement thwala vas-y
fais pas le malin je fais pas le malin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'autres
c'est pas vrai alors je vais dire j'ai
fait ça parce que je veux qu'il parte à
macao défonce le défonce le ca mon tour
[Applaudissements]
regardez bien ça va être vite après
ça fonctionne bien c'est bon ça va aller
très très vite ça avant que quelques
minutes
alors tu parlais de non-violence août
alors d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà en fait j'ai quelqu'un qui est là
pour toi je savais que j'allais me
mesurer à toi mais je vais m je suis le
mec le plus intelligent par rapport à
toi je suis pas sur la force sur le
l'esprit donc mais au monde fait il va
se mettre à ma place
en quelques secondes on exactement
[Musique]
tu as toi les buy qui vont avec
le
[Applaudissements]
pas violence
ces curés notre-dame combattants si
youcef qui s'occupera type leclerc
ou bien deux extrémités l'échec si
pacquiao
ça ne rigole pas quand on arrive à
battre nous servent il partira à macao
en séjour et sachez qu'il y aura
quelqu'un aussi qu'ils savent déjà
twitter qui partira à macao également
attention à ce que vous n'êtes pas les
gars 3 2
[Applaudissements]
il est sorti en kiosque ou pouvant le
ralenti c'est youssef qui sortent au
premier sens nancy 17h à macao a gagné
voilà c'est une chef qui sort en premier
le pied sans en premier le pays où ces
macaques
[Applaudissements]
non même pas masos ta couche culotte